10 6 - nephew 109 droit de vivre loin de
ses proches ont fini par s'y habituer
mais ne pas pouvoir les visiter ni les
fait revenir faute d'avoir les papiers
nécessaires
c'est de plus en plus douloureux pour
russian karimi femmes aidées en
l'absence d'une ambassade au canada et à
téhéran impossible de renouveler son
passeport iranien
c'est le prix à payer pour avoir un
avenir prospère dit-il en génie
électrique au canada
qu'est ce que tu as peur gloucester
comme ses étudiants il attend
impatiemment la réconciliation
diplomatique entre le canada et l'iran
les os et d'autres pour eux impossible
depuis trois ans de recevoir de l'argent
de ses parents en passant par les canaux
officiels
il faut prendre de risque mais pas
d'autre solution et ils sont nombreux à
l'école polytechnique de montréal
presque la moitié des étudiants au
doctorat sont venues d'iran pour moi la
première question était comment dire la
sécurité de l'emploi que j'avais pas
dans mon pays ils font partie de cette
nouvelle génération hautement qualifiés
quelqu'un a d'accueil à bras du vin même
qu'en 2014
c'est l'iran qui a fourni le plus grand
nombre d'immigrants au québec
6000 ou total puis vous savez c'est une
hémorragie pour la société iranienne que
deux paires tout ces gens qui ont été
éduqué mais hélas et marc chauffe les
comprend la vie en iran ce deviennent de
plus en plus difficile il est temps
selon elle que le canada renoue avec son
pays natal mais elle dit qu'il a
l'obligation morale de prioriser le
respect des droits de l'homme
mais pour elle la visite à paris et à
rome du président roi ni pour qui on a
caché les statues antiques de femmes
nues en dit long de couvrir et statut
dans le musée pour faire plaisir à
monsieur juan et c'est mesquin
est ce que l'occident est rendu à ce
pourrait pour pour les intérêts
économiques
pour le docteur ben arous sharif la
levée des sanctions pour
fit et des milliards que l'iran a à
offrir aux compagnies canadiennes
envoient un message inquiétant il tout
de centaines de centaines en iran même
avec toujours un nid qui a dit qu'il va
me le clae et pour ces étudiants venus
ici pour une stabilité nous faisons
légende iraniennes qui ont souffert de
cette fonction pour lui l'isolément a
assez duré ici tu as marre altérer ce
que radio canada montréal